welcome into this video playing draw it
on roll it up sweden just for hole ok ah
what's this kind of a weird vanoni ok
i'm going to prevent be five I know is
closing down the whole thing interesting
but ok it still should be quite a decent
position for four wide ok so all pretty
pretty standard do I play Bishop age 60
or not yeah probably taking this this
temple I am ok we probably and probably
get kicked with King age 898 and
whatever should do a five ready what
about this a five as long as I have the
time now again this is I can also just
do those things that's the theory the
standard way to play this okay if I take
how do i take mmm Knight takes yeah I
guess nine takes normal anyway but I was
just wondering if Bishop takes might be
an idea okay so my guess I take were the
noid yeah he's going he is on my three
bishop but i have my t6 here isn't this
isn't this something that I enter them
Kim should think about that too long
that this opens the long diagonal and
wow really and I get in the dead i get
in 9335 those kind of things this is
quite nice for me or here 95 you can
also just take it yeah come keep it
simple if I take it I'm just better with
the pawn on 186 just a question how much
better is wild we hear what doubling ok
let's not make a take take ages for that
it will be somewhat better for wine in
any case Pusha p.m.
okay rook f7 no I guess is coming what
doubling
gr not sure how do you actually make
progress in this position okay i'm doing
this looks very nice yeah with this pawn
that how exactly is wide winning
not so easy to to enter here yeah he
wants to do something on the dark square
Sam understandable
Quincy for this may be an idea I can
take on g3 with the bishop IAM and
there's no way forward unfortunately
when you don't see a way to win this
check
I can maybe in wait with the king hmm i
don't know maybe maybe it's still it's
still something
check
anyway forward like here I look is six
takes check on d6 it's not really really
don't have a good discovery their time
warning check
rookie 6 king cakes I have no discovery
roop t6 check it's not leading to
anything weird yeah okay I'm still
trying to win this over 30 seconds
because I mean like really assists and
able to do anything here rope g650 head
yes this is not not working at all
giving me the airport
hmm
threatening f8 Queen and winning and
that's it I think you found a move yeah
I don't they don't believe this really
three seconds yeah unbelievable stuff
check check guys got this bloody be to
pond yeah I very well deserved win he
was like in in terrible shape the whole
game I lost a bit of time here was
shuffling because I couldn't really
believe that this crap of a position was
still holding Jack this is a kind of
chess philosophy to just have a rotten
position all the way and try to win on
time because you have no other means to
win yeah okay I'm just invading and
maybe there's some better way forward
him jack yeah this is took some time and
this is of course insane yeah in voiding
the repetition here with with with this
position but whatever okay now I'm just
invading and here this is just winning
for white of course and this is
especially bad giving me the apron but
okay 30 seconds is the problem it's
still irritating enough so that he had
that he can continue yeah here can I can
go f8 immediately which is quicker yeah
yeah King takes root AJ the simple and
this is also doing a pretty good job
mopping it up but of course this wins
every move wins I would just need one
second ink and then then it's over yeah
okay it's useless to analyze this was
just a total one-way street the skin
okay thanks for watching